THE STATE OF XBOX:
After 7 years of hiding unit sales data for
the Xbox One, in 2022, Microsoft finally decided
release official sales numbers for the console,
and they were rather disappointing.
Throughout it’s lifetime, Microsoft was
only able to sell a total of 58 million consoles
which is isolation is a great number.
But in comparison to the competition and the
Xbox’s own predecessors, the number is rather
underwhelming.
For perspective, the PS4 which had an identical
lifespan was able to sell exactly double the
units at 117 million.
Even the PS5 which released just 3 years ago
is at 46.6 million units and is on track to
overtake the Xbox One in terms of sales.
The Xbox Series X/S was supposed to be the
console that finally turned around this trend
for Microsoft but it seems like the disparity
is only getting worse.
In fact, looking at globally monthly sales,
it appears that the Xbox is already starting
to lose steam while the PS5 is actually gaining
steam.
Now, it’s true that Nintendo has had consoles
that have flopped way harder like the Wii
U which barely sold 13 million units.
But, there’s a major difference between
a Nintendo console flopping and a Microsoft
console flopping.
You see, 57% of Nintendo’s total earnings
come from hardware sales meaning that they
are very much capable of selling a niche console
and still coming out on top financially.
The same, however, cannot be said about Microsoft
who sells the Xbox for a loss.
And this isn't speculation either.
Microsoft’s gaming CEO Phil Spencer has
admitted that every single Xbox Series X/S
console is sold for a loss of up to $200.
Since then, Microsoft has hiked the price
of the Series X in certain regions by less
than a $100, but even assuming that Microsoft
only loses $100 per console on average, the
Xbox Series X and S have already lost the
company over $2 billion.
And it hasn’t gained Microsoft any market
share or notoriety over the Playstation or
even the Switch.
It doesn’t seem like Microsoft is willing
to give up though as they’re throwing one
last hail mary with their $69 billion acquisition
of Activision Blizzard.
But will this acquisition actually turn things
around for Xbox or has Microsoft just dug
themselves into a $69 billion deeper hole.
THE ORIGINAL FLAME:
To understand why the modern Xbox is struggling,
we have to first understand how the Xbox grew
in popularity in the first place.
And that takes us all the way back to March
2, 1999, the day that the Playstation 2 was
announced.
If you didn’t know, the Playstation 2 would
go onto be the best selling console of all
time selling over 155 million units.
Hearing this, a lot of you are probably inclined
to think that the Xbox was an offensive move
from Microsoft.
They say how successful the PS2 was and they
wanted a piece of the pie, but that’s actually
not how things played out.
It turns out the the Xbox was actually more
of a defensive move.
You see, the PS2 wasn’t just a gaming console.
It was actually more of a multi media device,
something that gaming companies have only
built on over the years.
It could play CDs and DVDs and Microsoft began
to fear that this would allow Sony to eat
into the personal computer market.
So, Microsoft decided to flex on Sony by showcasing
their own multi media technology suite: DirectX.
DirectX is basically the middleman in Windows
machines that interprets code and translates
it into graphics and sound.
DirectX was not only robust and reliable but
it was familiar to developers because given
that it was from Microsft, it worked seamlessly
with Windows 2000.
So, Microsoft decided to just port Windows
2000 and DirectX into a dedicated gaming console
called the DirectXBox or Xbox for short.
And the pitch for developers was that developing
games for the Xbox would be similar to developing
PC games and the pitch worked.
Alongside the launch of the original Xbox
on November 15, 2001, we would see the launch
of a legendary gaming series: Halo.
And this brings us into the first factor that
made the Xbox successful: iconic exclusive
games.
Naturally, a lot gamers hate exclusive games
because it forces them to buy multiple consoles
just to play all of the best games on the
market.
But, from a corporate perspective, exclusive
games are critical when it comes to building
a loyal fanbase and boosting sales.
Microsoft understood this perfectly initially
as the Xbox was defined by a slew of exclusive
games and series like Halo, Forza, the Witcher,
Left 4 Dead, Call of Duty 2, Elder Scrolls
3, and Doom 3 just to name a few.
But over the years, this list has gotten smaller
and smaller to point that Xbox Series X and
S exclusives can be counted on one hand.
It’s basically just Forza Horizon 5, Halo
Infinite, Starfield, and Microsoft Flight
Simulator.
I suspect that most simulator fans would prefer
to play Microsoft Flight Simulator on a PC,
so the Xbox really only has Forza Horizon
5 and Halo Infinite going for it.
When you look at games that are exclusive
to or optimized for the PS5 on the other hand,
you have all of these.
Seeing this, it’s no wonder why the Playstation
and the Switch have been crushing the Xbox.
Both of them have a bunch of exclusive titles
that make the console worth owning unlike
the Xbox.
But, how did the Microsoft even end up in
this situation?
Wasn’t the Xbox supposed to be the easiest
console to develop for because of it’s similarities
with Windows?
Well, it turns out that that by itself is
not enough.
MICROSOFT DROPS THE BALL:
One of the biggest factors holding back developers
from preferring the Xbox over the Playstation
is its discrepancy in performance.
The Playstation has historically always been
more powerful than the Xbox but extra power
also came with a higher price tag.
The Xbox 360 for example launched at $400
while the PS3 launched at $500 to $600.
Adjusting for inflation, the PS3 cost as much
as $880.
So, the Xbox was able to reach a demographic
that the Playstation may have never reached
making it worth it to develop Xbox games.
But over the years, Sony has slightly pulled
back their prices while Microsoft has slightly
pushed up their prices such that the Playstation
and Xbox are pretty much identically priced.
But while the price of the consoles are the
same, the same cannot be said about their
performance.
The PS4 was objectively more powerful than
the Xbox.
In fact, as much as 40% more powerful.
This disparity has only been exacerbated by
the new generation of consoles because Microsoft
has gone out of their way to launch a lower
end Xbox called the Series S which game developers
aren’t exactly a fan of.
They’re basically having to nerf their games
and graphics to accommodate for the Series
S. In fact, some games have even been delayed
because developers have had a tough time nerfing
performance for the Series S without sacrificing
performance on the Series X.
This is rather annoying even as a secondary
release.
So, I think you can see why developers are
hesitant to bet an exclusive flagship on the
Xbox.
But, the whole rivalry between the the Playstation
and the Xbox only tell half the story because
there’s very much a dark horse at play:
PC gaming.
Remember how one of the biggest advantages
of the Xbox originally was it’s similarities
to PC?
It was easy to port games from PC to Xbox
and vice versa.
Well, this has actually turned into a massive
disadvantage because there is no such thing
as true Xbox exclusive.
Basically every Xbox exclusive is also available
on PC.
This wasn’t a big deal back in the 2000s
and early 2010s because only the super nerds
with massive budgets gamed on PC.
But ever since the launch of AMD Ryzen, building
PCs has become a lot more budget friendly
and popular.
This trend has only been accelerated by the
explosion of esports which has made PC gaming
cooler than it ever was.
What does all of this mean you ask?
Well, if you really want to play Microsoft
exclusive games, it often makes more sense
to just get a PC than an Xbox.
The PC can not only run the games much better
but it can also do a lot more than just gaming.
If all of that wasn’t bad enough, the Xbox
has been facing another major obstacle as
well which is the larger interests of Microsoft.
Since the launch of the original Xbox, Microsoft
has grown from a few hundred billion company
to a few trillion dollar company.
And considering that prosecutors wanted to
break up Microsoft back when they were just
a few hundred billion dollars, Microsoft is
a bigger target now than ever.
So, the last thing they want to do is show
off monopolistic tendencies by launching a
bunch of exclusive games just to winover the
gaming market.
In fact, Satya Nadella has gone on record
stating that he wants to end Xbox exclusives
and that the ball is in Sony’s court now.
But if that’s the case, why in the world
did Microsoft just complete their biggest
acquisition of all time and spend $69 billion
to buy Activision Blizzard?
CHANGING LANES:
From a general sense, it’s obvious why Microsoft
bought Activision Blizzard.
It’s obviously to control a larger portion
of the gaming market and make more money.
But, if we take a closer look at the acquisition
and how Microsoft executives talk about the
acquisition, we’ll see that the acquisition
is less of an expansion play and more of a
pivot play.
And we can take it from the horses mouth itself,
the CEO of Microsoft Gaming Phil Spencer.
When asked about the reasoning behind the
Activision Blizzard acquisition, Phil said
quote “The biggest gaming platform on the
planet is mobile phones.”
“One and a half billion people play on mobile
phones.”
“We really started the discussions, internally
at least, on Activision Blizzard around the
capability they had on mobile, and then PC
with Blizzard.
Those are the two things that were really
driving our interest.”
In other words, Microsoft bought Activision
Blizzard to dominate the mobile and PC space
not the console space.
This might be a bit confusing given that a
lot of see Activision as the OG console game
maker, but it turns out that they have evolved
quite a bit over the years.
In fact, 43% of their revenue comes from mobile
gaming which is the company’s top performer
largely due to mobile hits like Call of Duty:
Warzone Mobile.
In fact, console gaming is now their worst
performing division only accounting for a
quarter of their revenue.
Microsoft isn’t too concerned about this
though because they’re looking to branch
out beyond consoles because well, the Xbox
isn’t even doing all that well and there’s
a massive gaming market beyond that.
Would Microsoft actually put so much history
behind them and completely pivot their gaming
strategy though?
Well, if Satya Nadella has one super power,
it’s not letting ego cloud his business
judgement.
If it’s better to run servers on Linux than
Windows, he’ll do it.
If it’s better to expand Office to iOS devices
and put down the Windows Phone, he’ll do
it.
If it’s better to kill Internet Explorer
and develop a new Edge that runs on Google’s
Chromium, well, he’ll do it.
So, considering his track record, I don’t
think he’ll hesitate to make similar decision
with the gaming industry.
If the Xbox simply isn’t cutting it and
mobile and PC gaming is working out a lot
better, he’ll shift Microsoft’s focus
to mobile and PC gaming.
And it seems that this is already starting
to happen.
The next Xbox is envisioned to be less of
a traditional gaming console that competes
directly with the Playstation and be more
of a hybrid cloud gaming platform.
What exactly that means is not clear but one
thing is for sure, Microsoft is not afraid
to experiment and take risks with the Xbox.
That’s arguably why they launched 2 different
consoles Series X and S in the first place.
They understood that the old approach simply
wasn’t working, so they wanted to try something
new.
Unfortunately, it doesn’t seem like the
new strategy worked either and who knows how
the cloud based console will play out.
So, the glory days of the Xbox may very well
be behind us, but don’t count out Microsoft
just yet.
While they may not be the king of console
gaming, they may very well become the king
of the gaming industry at large.
With historically high interest rates, the
appeal bills and bonds is the higher than
ever, yet traditional brokerages haven’t
really adapted with the times.
They still expect people to use clunky bond
tables, scroll through long overwhleming lists,
and even use virtual keyboards till recently.
And that’s why we created our own modern
bond platform: Silo.
At Silo, we prioritize the user experience
and the ease of finding and investing in the
issuers you know and trust, so that you too
can lock in high yields.
Also, choosing a strong user experience doesn’t
mean sacrificing on safety.
Every Silo account is insured by $500,000
in SIPC insurance and $2.5 million in FDIC
insurance.
Also, all funds deposited on the platform
will be maintained by our trusted custodian,
Interactive Brokers, who has experience managing
$373 billion worth of assets over the past
45 years.
Unlike Microsoft, Sony is killing it with
the PS5 but the problem for Sony is that that’s
the only place they’re killing it.
Check out this video to learn more.